in focus now general jack keane retired
four star general fox news senior
strategic analyst and chairman at the
institute for the study of war general
thank you for being here today
first of all i want you to react to some
of trey's reporting there on what would
seem to be strategy
by putin and i have been calling his
russian forces terrorists because they
are raining down terror now by hitting
these civilian targets
well it's almost like there's two wars
taking place one in the south and one in
the north because they're so different
the one in the south is is finally
beginning to succeed from a russian
perspective they've taken kirsten which
is a critical city in the south they
surrounded mario pole which is on the
east and their forces are approaching at
desa they have amphibious landing ships
approaching it likely sending
some forces from kirsan in that
direction as well the purpose and the
strategy that the russians are using
here
is to cut the ukrainians off from the
sea which is where all of their imports
and exports transit
and also to build the land bridge that
we've talked about many times to crimea
that will likely succeed it will take
several more days the units that are
doing this are from the southern
military district many of them are based
out of crimea and in the vicinity of
crimea in russia and the fact is that
this these units have trained together
and exercised together for a number of
years and i think it is a contributor to
the success that they're enjoying in the
north
operations are largely stalled as our
reporters are are reporting they even
tried a third axis to commit the key the
last couple of days and that got stalled
as well
so they have real challenges there a lot
of them are logistic challenges but
they're also
dealing with the units themselves he
brought
units into belarus that are now
conducting the main effort on on kiev
from the eastern part of russia many of
them are hodge pods of units they've
never exercised on large scale
together before and yet they were given
the task of the main effort they're
having significant logistics problems as
we have been accurately reporting and
that's got to be
a couple of to ukrainian excuse me
general because i i want to get this in
here really quickly that's got to be
such a benefit to ukrainian forces as
they wait literally for ammo to show up
i mean it's taken a while for those
materials to move to where the forces
are fighting
russia to reach them real quickly let's
get to this ukraine claims it has killed
a top russian general the most senior
figure to have been killed during the
invasion so far they say it represents a
major blow to russia's operation the
general just one of more than 9 000
russian troops ukraine says it has
killed
since the invasion began
uh more than a week ago now by a day
you're talking about
deficiencies in the fighting force what
does this do taking off a top general
well it's notable and he's a leader and
the unit suffers as a result of it but
it's it's not the degree of significance
that that they're claiming there's no
general on that battlefield out there
that's indispensable uh the fact is
what's happening with the organizations
are really the issue the reason why the
operation in the north is stalled
ukrainian resistance is a factor
logistics is the other one and as those
as those vehicles we've seen the
pictures of them you know sit on a road
and they're and they're so vulnerable
the ukrainians certainly are able to
take advantage of that
particularly at night when
they they're able to operate with
concealment and with cover i also
believe
there's a lot the united states could be
doing here we have covert capability to
interdict those convoys it is risk
associated with that
uh to be sure you have to look at the
benefits of it but we we have developed
this capability over a number of years
and it gives us deniability we can also
help uh covertly to bring in supplies
right now the
what's happening is
the ukrainians have to go to
go to poland at the border pick up the
supplies and drive them back
at some point the russians are likely
going to cut that off we got to be
prepared to
conduct aerial resupply and pinpoint air
drops and landing at remote airfields we
can do that covertly it's a matter of
having us there
and our willingness to accept the risk
uh generally we accept the risk is the
issue i have a lot still to cover with
you and i want to pause you there
respectfully because you were the person
with all the expertise on the one thing
that zielinski says he wants right now
and you mention anything about airspace
and you get everybody's attention
because we have some of the best fighter
pilots on the planet but we cannot
engage
provocatively we're being told by the
pentagon we can't be the first but what
you're talking about is air support
where we could play a role please go
into detail on that
well what i'm saying is we can conduct
covert operations to conduct pinpoint
air drops
and also
uh to do resupply at remote airfields
that don't even have lights i mean we
have all this capability can't get in to
the details of it but just generally
speaking
we have conducted covert operations
before for years we have the the people
who do that we have a an intelligence
agency uh that goes to title 50 to do
something like that the president has to
issue a finding and there's risk
associated with it i'm not suggesting
it's not and it has to be looked at
carefully but it certainly we should be
on the menu of things that we should be
looking at particularly if we're all in
and dead serious about giving ukrainians
everything they need
and and this is this is a part of that i
mean if you're listening to zielinski
who has one of the best
uh abilities right now certainly far
outreaching vladimir putin who's been at
it for years
as a president of of another nation i
guess you could call on that he's a
dictator um but but zielinski outweighs
putin's ability to communicate and if
you listen to him he's saying that's the
kind of help he needs that and the
intelligence and so it will be
interesting everybody's got to be all in
but if we're part of that general i know
from your own history of leadership
our men and women are more than ready to
do that cover work real quickly what is
the risk
well the risk is detection and and
and the fact that well it looks like we
just committed an act of war against the
russians that's that's the risk
and and
our national
uh security team will take that take the
president through those risks and
options my concern
uh with this administration from the
outset has been their timidity and the
fact that they
they're somewhat risk-averse and and
what i'm calling for here is a little
bit of imagination and a little bit of
spine and and i think we can provide
some significant help to the ukrainians
and minimize the risk of going to war
with russia over it i just wrote that
down
what a four-star general says you need
uh is some imagination and a little bit
of spine you have given us uh some
things to work with a pep talk and a
whole lot of facts and experience and
i'm very grateful every time you're in
focus general thank you
yeah great talking to you harris as
always hi winner brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now